Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW. Unsere kleine Welt. Mein Name ist Tim Brittlav.
Und ich begrüße alle zur achtundfünfzigsten Ausgabe von UKW und das heißt heute ist äh Corona Weekly angesagt
Wir nehmen jetzt mal ausnahmsweise nicht an einem Freitag auf, sondern es musste aus
praktischen Gründen auf den Samstag verschoben werden, aber ansonsten ist alles wie gehabt, denn ich bin hier und mit mir ist natürlich Pavel, hallo Pavel.
Ja und wir wollen mal wieder äh zusammenfassen, was so Alfings, Corona aus unserer bundesdeutschen Perspektive so uns äh so mitzuteilen äh hat
Ja
und ähm wir blicken auf eine gar nicht so ereignisreiche Woche, aber ein paar Sachen sind schon passiert und ein paar Erkenntnisse,
haben wir schon gewonnen, die wir mit euch teilen möchten. Heute ist dann also der dreißigste Januar. Der Januar ist sozusagen durch,
Und ja, da wollen wir natürlich erstmal schauen, ob wir die erhofften.
Ergebnisse erzielt haben, was so das Infektionsgeschehen betrifft. Und da fangen wir doch einfach mal mit an, mit dem Zahlenwerk.
Hast du dein Buch konsuliert dein digitales Zahlenbuch.
Jahr habe ich und ja, es sieht verhalten positiv aus, weil.
Zahlen fallen. So,
sowohl bei der Zahl der Neuinfektionen als auch bei der Zahl der Toten, also bei den Neuinfektionen sind wir ungefähr,
bei zwölftausendvierhundert am Tag immer noch,
'ne ganze Menge und bei den Toten leider ähm immer noch auch bei siebenhundertdreißig pro Tag, aber,
zum ersten Mal seit Wochen.
Jahr rückläufig so und zwar jetzt seit über einer Woche rückläufig und,
ist auf jeden Fall erfreulich und ja der sieben Tage RW liegt bei,
null Komma acht neun sagen null Komma neun und.
Null Komma neun ist halt so einen Wert, wo man schon irgendwo hinkommt, also nämlich nach unten, äh wenn man das schafft, das zu halten.
Aber äh man ist mit null Komma neun jetzt von der eins äh und darüber halt nicht wirklich weit entfernt. Und.
Wenn man jetzt guckt, wenn's jetzt so bleiben würde bei null Komma neun, dann.
Werden wir irgendwo in ja vier, fünf Wochen ähm.
Würden wir die berühmte fünfzig pro Hunderttausender Grenze bei den äh Institzen, bei den Neuinfektionen erreichen.
Und dann nochmal fünf Wochen später würden wir die sichere zwanziger Zone erreichen, wenn wir halt im Schnitt bei null Komma neun,
bleiben würden. Wenn sich jetzt aber.
Der Wert nur um null Komma null fünf, also auf null Komma neun fünf erhöhen würde, dann brauchen wir Monat länger.
Um die fünfzig zu erreichen und fast nochmal zwei Monate mehr um die.
Sicheren zwanzig zu erreichen. Das heißt, die Situation ist halt sehr, sehr instabil und eigentlich müssten wir eher äh weiter runter, um bisschen mehr Sicherheitsabstand zu kriegen und.
Wir haben halt auch genau null Potential.
Für irgendwelche Öffnungen so,
weil selbst nur das Gerede über Öffnungen so äh,
wenn das den Eindruck erweckt, ja, die Zahlen sind jetzt schon wieder gefallen, es ist weniger gefährlich. Allein das kann,
Verhaltensänderung hervorrufen, weil die Leute glauben, dass es jetzt nicht mehr so gefährlich ist und ruckzuck äh äh sind wir wieder äh,
null Komma null fünf höher plus natürlich die Verbreitung der ganzen neuen Varianten kann uns also auch da leicht,
jetzt nach oben treiben. Insofern instabile Situation und um.
Überhaupt öffnen zu können. So braucht man halt zwei Dinge, entweder eine super niedrige Inzidenz.
So in Größenordnung von, ich würde sagen, ein, zwei pro hunderttausend, auf jeden Fall deutlich unter zehn. Dann spielt der RWT nämlich auch nicht mehr so die große Rolle, weil dann hat man somit vereinzelnen.
Ausbrüchen zu tun, die man dann hoffentlich in den Griff kriegt, aber.
Ansonsten zum Beispiel um die Schulen aufzumachen, müssten wir auf einen Ehrwert von null Komma sieben oder besser kommen,
damit nach der Öffnung wir äh überhaupt die Zahlen untereinzahlt werden, weil so wie es sich im Moment,
gestaltet würde jede Art von Lokorum,
uns sofort über die eins wieder äh drauftreiben und die Zahlen würden sofort wieder einsteigen. Ja,
Das ist die die Situation und ähm.
Wenn man sich aber jetzt den gesamten Verlauf der R-Kurve seit Beginn der Panemie anguckt, also ich rede jetzt von äh sieben Tage erwerten,
dann haben wir die null Komma sieben nie erreicht, ja.
Also das Beste war, ich meine null Komma sieben fünf und das auch nur tageweise und selbst unter null Komma acht,
sind wir maximal einmal so jeweils zehn Tage lang gewesen oder so, aber nie jetzt vier oder sechs Wochen, ja. Da kommt man mal froh sein, wenn wir überhaupt,
unter eins geblieben sind? Und das ist an die Global Situation.
Was jetzt äh also global deutschlandwei.
Die deutschlandweite Situation. Lassen Sie uns nochmal ganz kurz äh bei der deutschlandweiten Situation bleiben, das nochmal ein bisschen einzuordnen. Also wir sind jetzt mit den Institzen,
ungefähr so bei hundertzehn, ne, wenn ich das so richtig sehe, ne? Also ich beziehe mich jetzt leider äh gerade wahrscheinlich auf die Zahl von,
gestern, also vom Freitag, da waren es äh hundertzwölf jetzt einen Tag später.
Hundertdrei, also da merkt man schon die Tage machen jetzt schon einen Unterschied und wenn man jetzt das eben halten würde, dann könnte man das wahrscheinlich auch bald ablesen. Aber insgesamt ist es halt auch noch.
Sehr, es gibt auch noch Länder, die die wo das Infektionsgeschehen noch sehr stark ist. Das heißt so der Gesamtwert der,
wird halt nur dadurch gedrückt, dass es ein paar Länder gibt, wo es schon besser ist, ne? Aber sogar Schleswig-Holstein.
Die war doch auch vor ein paar.
Wochen auch schon mal besser als sie jetzt dastehen, ne? Also es man merkt ja auch wie immer wieder so ein Hin und Her Schwanken zwischen den Ländern.
Das unterstreicht was du gesagt hast, ne? Also kaum fühlt man sich irgendwie halbwegs sicher oder auch nur besser als irgendjemand anders dann bricht sofort wieder alles ein und der Quatsch geht schon wieder von vorne los.
Also sagen laut RKI sind wir deutlich äh unter hundert jetzt sogar also um die um die neunzig rum, neunzighundert jetzt Deutschlandweit kann man sagen.
Laut dem RKI.
Ja laut, also laut meiner Rechnung hundertdrei und laut eigentlich der RKI-Rechnung müssten sechsundneunzig sein, aber die hatten offiziell noch eine andere Zahl ausgewiesen.
Na ja, weil die sind ja halt auch immer wieder das kennen wir ja schon, ne. RKI zählt nicht alles, was du zählst, du zählst halt die letzten vierzehn Tage,
also mit mit verspäteten Meldungen, die verspäteten Meldungen auch noch mit rein und das macht das RKI nicht, deswegen sind diese RKI-Zahlen halt generell niedriger.
Ja. Also entweder gleich oder niedrig.
Wobei, ja, also RKI sagt gerade heute auch neunzig Komma neun als sieben Tage Instit. Ich weiß nicht, warum da so viele Fälle gerade äh bei denen unter den Tisch fallen, aber.
Das weiß auch nur, dass RKI hoffen wir, dass sie es zumindest wissen.
Ja
Ähm ach so und ansonsten ja beim Bundesländern halt ist nach wie vor so Sachsen-Anhalt, Thüringen, Brandenburg, Sachsen.
So am schlimmsten betroffen, aber es hat sich auch in den Ländern deutlich nivelliert. Also sind jetzt alle unter zweihundert äh wieder auf jeden Fall und äh ja.
In den meisten Ländern geht's auch ganz gut.
So, also mit RWE inzwischen ja null Komma acht eins.
Im Moment Brandenburg äh gerade und dann aber auch eins Komma null zwei in Bremen im Moment mit dem mit dem höchsten RWAT und Saarland ist auch ziemlich genau bei eins.
Im Moment,
und das heißt halt, dass sich trotz dreimal verschärften Lokdown trotz noch nicht so richtig,
dich weiter Verbreitung dieser infektiösen UK-Variante sich immer noch.
Acht bis neun Leute äh anstecken bei zehn Leuten, die vorher angesteckt waren.
Und ja, das ist nach wie vor verdammt viel Ansteckung äh.
Vor allem, wenn man sich jetzt anschaut, wie sich eigentlich so diese ganzen Maßnahmen doch normalisiert haben. Ich meine, das ist jetzt wieder subjektive Wahrnehmung, aber ich habe so mittlerweile den Eindruck, dass man einfach,
Überall Masken sieht,
Ja, was heißt überall? Ich bin kaum unterwegs, also ich kann's für dich sehr schwer äh beurteilen. Also ganz offensichtlich werden Maßnahmen auch äh breitflächig ignoriert und ich habe halt so ein bisschen ähm
die Businesswelt in Verdacht, dass sie dann halt einfach nach wie vor in Büros und so weiter einfach nicht genug tun, um hier die Zahlen runterzubringen und das ist eigentlich,
Eigentlich ist das wirklich betrübsam, ne? Weil letztlich kann man ja daraus ableiten,
Selbst wenn's so bliebe wie jetzt, was eigentlich schon nicht wünschenswert ist, ne, du hast es ja gerade auch immer an Zahlen gefasst.
Würde das müsste das eigentlich bedeuten, dass wir die Maßnahmen, wie wir sie jetzt haben, einschließlich geschlossener Schulen bis Ende März,
noch beibehalten müssten auf jeden F.
Ja
Und ich bin mir nicht so richtig sicher, ob das die Debatte irgendwie äh hergibt.
Ne, im Moment war's wohl so, dass bei Meinungsumfragen die äh,
Befürworter eines harten Kurses äh immer noch mehr werden im Moment,
da ist wohl gerade die Bevölkerung der Politik etwas voraus. So also im Moment kann man,
wohl nicht unbedingt sich profilieren ähm als äh ja.
Öffnungsvertreter.
Öffnungsvertreter oder Verharmloser oder wie auch immer ähm Großteil der Leute. Ich glaube zwei Drittel ungefähr ähm.
Findet die Maßnahmen entweder richtig oder hätte gerne mehr. Ja und.
Gut nochmal, was halt natürlich auch immer zum Blick auf die rohen Zahlen dazugehört, äh ist einen Blick auf die Tests, weil.
Ja die Zahlen.
Durch das Testregime immer wieder auch äh verzerrt werden und da ist es so.
Dass sie Tests wieder etwas abgenommen haben.
Ähm gegenüber der der Vorwoche sind's jetzt acht Prozent weniger Tests.
Ja, eins Komma null sieben Millionen Tests wurden durchgeführt, aber,
positiv rate ist auch zurückgegangen. Auf jetzt neun Komma neun sieben Prozent. Ähm das ist ein Rückgang um viereinhalb Prozent und das.
Bedeutet man als Interpretation, dass tatsächlich auch das Infektionsgeschehen zurückgegangen.
Ist und nicht nur weniger getestet wurde. Allerdings,
die Zahlen ein etwas stärkeren Rückgang wieder,
als er tatsächlich stattgefunden hat. Also die Zahlen sind ein bisschen zu optimistisch, aber minimal. Ja das.
Kann man so aus den aus den Testzahlen schließen.
Das ist ungefähr ist es ungefähr die positiven Quote, wie wir sie Ende November hatten.
Und die positiven Quote sich das anschaut ist,
aber einen für sich genommen, verdammt gutes Spiegelbild auch des gesamten Pandimieverlaufs eigentlich.
Also wenn man nur die positiven Quote hätte, äh könnte man da auch schon.
Extrem viel auf das Infektionsgeschehen schließen und.
Das ist auf jeden Fall ein ein sehr guter Indikator und,
sagen kann, ja wir sind jetzt wo wieder zurück.
November werte aber,
wir sind jetzt immer noch in der Todeszone, sagen wir mal, wenn das, wenn jetzt die dritte Welle, wenn ich mir das jetzt so als Mount Everest vorstelle, so dann sind wir immer noch im oberen Drittel grade, also.
Müssen auch noch zwei Drittel des Weges, was jetzt die die.
Positiv Rate angeht, noch zurücklegen und mehr als die Hälfte noch des Weges bei Neuinfektionen.
Tja, Leute, also weiterhin das volle Programm. Abstand halten.
Fernhalten, so dürft das auch alles ist, aber es hilft ja sonst nix. Also es ist einfach äh.
Sonst uns wird's nie besser. Und wir müssen das geschehen in gerade in dieser Zeit, also es ist auch,
würde sogar sagen, nie war es so wichtig wie heute, jetzt ist halt einfach Februar,
Und März, das ist halt einfach Infektionssaison, das ist einfach das, wo Infektionskrankheiten generell resieren und wenn wir uns jetzt halt auch noch den,
ja, wenn man's jetzt auch noch neue äh Virusmutationen eintreten, die sich vielleicht noch mehr verbreiten, dann dann kommen wir nirgendswo hin.
Dann bleibt das einfach noch bis im Juni so.
Blick nach Berlin nochmal, da gucke ich ja immer äh auch noch auf etwas andere Aspekte. Also erstmal.
Kurz gesagt ist die Situation sehr ähnlich wie im Bund in Berlin,
auch Rückgänge bei der Zahl der Toten und bei der Zahl der Neuinfektionen interessant ist da, aber auch noch,
Blick auf die sieben Tage Institen in äh in verschiedenen Altersgruppen, den wir da immer machen und da,
ist überall einen Rückgang und erfreulicherweise jetzt in Berlin, in der Altersgruppe achtzig plus,
einen sehr starker Rückgang. Es ist immer noch die Altersgruppe mit der höchsten Institut Tests wobei.
Was mir bei der ganzen Institanzbetrachtung äh auch.
Immer wieder auffällt ist, dass wir leider keine Zahlen haben über.
Äh die Altersverteilung bei den Tests. Die werden halt eigentlich extrem wichtig zu wissen, wie viel Leute denn in welcher Altersgruppe jetzt getestet wurden,
überhaupt, weil äh,
ich mir nämlich ziemlich sicher bin, dass äh einfach bei besonders bei Kindern die ja.
Symptomatisch sind zu einem sehr großen Teil gar keine auch einfach weniger Tests gemacht werden und dann natürlich auch nur eine geringere Institanz dabei rauskommen kann. Aber um wie viel.
Wissen wir nicht. Ja auch wieder so ein so ein Ding. Und was aber auch sehr erfreulich ist, dass wir.
Die Institutionen bei Kindern im ja Schulpflichtigen Alter so zwischen fünf und fünfzehn Jahren die sind extrem niedrig.
Also die sind äh massiv zurückgegangen, haben sich teilweise mehr,
als halbiert. Ähm so und auf einem zweieinhalb Till zurückgegangen oder sogar auf nur einen einen Viertel,
bei den fünfzehn bis Neunzehnjährigen und das hat sehr wahrscheinlich mit den Schulschließungen äh zu tun.
Weil wir gerade in Berlin auch bei fünfzehn bis neunzehnjährigen hatten wir.
Rekordinstitzen von über dreihundertsechzig und wir sind jetzt auf,
dreiundachtzig runter und bei den fünf bis zehnjährigen ja.
Ist es von hundertvierzig auf vierundvierzig runtergegangen und.
Ja und zehn bis vierzehn äh von zweihundertfünfzig auf neunundsechzig. Also deutlich. Ja, ist auffällig, dass wirklich.
Dieses junge Segment aufatmet und das ist korreliert ziemlich klar mit den Schulschließungen. Kaum dass Weihnachtsferien angefangen haben ging das ging das runter.
Und ja auch noch so ein weiterer Blick die Belegung
der Intensivstation oder generell Krankenhausbetten. Auch da haben wir in Berlin erfreulicherweise einen Rückgang, wobei wir einen recht deutlichen Rückgang bei äh den.
Nicht Intensivpatienten, also bei den Normalperipher-Stationären Patienten.
Haben wir so jetzt vom vom Gipfel ungefähr zwanzig Prozent Rückgang, aber bei den Intensivstationen,
geht es nur eher sehr langsam zurück. Also da haben wir vielleicht einen zehnprozentigen Rückgang und bei den Beatmungen auch,
So also schwere Fälle äh nach wie vor noch.
Auf einem hohen Niveau, sie Intensivstation kann man sagen.
Haben noch ganz schön zu kämpfen,
Ja, also in Berlin sind's immer noch alleine so über ja vierhundert Leute, die auf Intensivstationen liegen, wenn man sich das jetzt so vorstellt, also vierhundert Leute,
auf einem Haufen alleine ist schon, das ist schon so eine komplette Schule und dann stellt man sich jetzt vierhundert,
äh so ein Saal mit vierhundert Betten äh vor äh wie alle auf der Intensivstation äh sind, alle umgeben von Intensivpflegern,
äh das ist schon krass, finde ich. Vielleicht noch dann zum Schluss den Blick ins Ausland.
Mein da fallen die Neuinfektionen.
Fast überall auch Spanien ähm,
war bis vor zwei Tagen noch ziemlich auf dem Weg nach oben äh zeichnet sich möglicherweise jetzt aber auch eine eine Umkehr ab,
und äh insbesondere aber UK und Irland, die ja diesen hohen Anteil an B hundertsiebzehn Mutationen haben.
Ja schaffen es auch gerade dagegen anzukämpfen und in UK äh es aber schon klar, dass die Schulen dort mindestens bis zum achten dritten geschlossen bleiben. Das ist wohl die.
Dortige Beschlusslage.
Ja es stimmt. Also die meisten europäischen Länder.
Zeigen einen Rückgang, einzige richtige Ausnahme sind so Montenegro und Portugal, Portugal ist es gerade richtig wild. Die haben irgendwie Institzen von tausendzweihundert, also.
Also da ist grad die Köcke richtig am Dampfen, das sind so Werte, die wir nie erreicht haben und äh ja, hoffentlich auch nicht erreichen werden.
Ja, sowas gab's denn sonst noch in Belgien und Tschechien gab's noch diese Dimensionen.
Ja, aber auch Tschechien hat sich ja gefangen. Ich meine, die sind auch noch auf einem sehr hohen Level, die sind so bei siebenhundert ungefähr,
das ist alles viel zu viel.
Und die Tschechen haben auch dann gleich noch eine Welle mehr schon hingelegt. Äh die sind ja schon,
quasi in der dritten Welle eigentlich euer Handy haben die dritte Welle hinter sich gerade. Wenn man so will, während die erste Welle gar nicht einen einen Welchen war.
Ja, war dann da für die zweite und dritte umso höher,
Zwei Stellen auch, wenn man in der Muster gucken, gut,
ich glaube nicht, dass es eine allgemeine Regel ist, wenn man in der ersten Welle besonders gut war, dass man dann hinterher in der zweiten Welle besonders unvorsichtig war, glaube ich, so nicht verallgemeinert, aber für ein paar Länder trifft das auf jeden Fall zu und,
glaube ich in Deutschland auch mit einem Grund, warum man.
Solange gezögert hat und erstmal so stark hat, anwachsen lassen, weil man dachte alles. Haben wir ja beim in der ersten Welle irgendwie alles gut hingekriegt und jetzt kann ja nur besser werden,
und äh ja war ganz offensichtlich nicht so.
Irland, was auch hart betroffen war, ist so auf fünfzig äh abgerutscht, was schon ein sehr guter Wert ist und ganz weit vorne in Europa ist, derzeit Island. Die haben eine Instinenz von zwei Komma neun.
Das ist mal eine Zahl, die man händeln kann, so. Also das ist die sind sozusagen kurz vor Sirokovit, ne.
Und wahrscheinlich streben sie das auch an, wie ich sie kenne. Tja, soweit der internationale äh Ausblick.
Jetzt wollen wir nochmal ein bisschen schauen, ja was ist denn eigentlich so im Bereich Maßnahmen passiert? Also wir hatten ja jetzt auch nochmal eine.
Quasi Verschärfung, ich weiß gar nicht, haben wir das letzte Mal schon drüber gesprochen.
Nicht.
Nicht so richtig, ne?
Ja, es finde ich, es gibt ja dann jetzt diese Home-Office-Empfehlung.
So ja und dann.
Weiß ich gar nicht irgendwie so richtig durchgreifende Maßnahmen über die es Diskussionen großgegeben hätte, fällt dir da was ein.
Ja also es Trend geht zu FFP zwei Masken, ne? Ich glaube das ist so ein bisschen das neue Ding und die sieht man jetzt auch echt immer häufiger.
Das stimmt. Also ich habe in im Supermarkt als ich da jetzt neulich mal einkaufen war, nur FFB zwei gesehen.
Das scheint tatsächlich ganz gut zu funktionieren, auch ich glaube in der äh im ÖPNV ist es vorgeschrieben jetzt. Das sind sicherlich äh gute Maßnahmen.
Wobei ich sagen muss, hm.
Dass ich äh ja die FFB zwei,
Masken doch etwas gewöhnungsbedürftiger finde,
vor allem wenn man die richtig angelegt hat, dann ist der Atemwiderstand doch spürbar höher.
Was dann erstmal gegenüber OP Masken, also schon zu einem Beklemmungsgefühl führen kann. Also ich musste mich da so erstmal dran gewöhnen. Muss ich sagen.
Ja, aber man kann sich dran gewöhnen.
Man kann sich dran vergewöhnen und man kriegt auch genug Luft und man.
Erstickt nicht äh daran, aber äh ja.
Kann sie auch besser wegfalten. Also ich find's ja am Ende sogar praktischer.
Ja, sie sind praktischer und ich meine, sie haben den entscheidenden Vorteil, dass richtig getragen sie hm.
Ja tatsächlich die Ansteckungsgefahr um neunzig bis fünfundneunzig Prozent reduzieren können. Das Problem ist aber das richtig tragen.
Was mir aufgefallen ist, ist dass im Gegensatz zu den OP Masken,
den Blechstreifen, der ja meistens gerade ist. Die Leute den Blechstreifen nicht genug giegen. Ist ja bei den meisten FFB zwei Masken dieser,
Nasenpügel, Blechstreifen erstmal geknickt und man muss den öffnen. Was,
aber bei den meisten Leuten dazu führt, dass die rechts und links neben der Nase dann äh riesige Luft ein und Auslassschlitze haben. Was also.
Von daher recht nochmal wichtig äh gucken, äh dass man bei den FFP zwei Masken den,
Metallbügel äh richtig aufbiegt und dann in die Form bringt, dass das halt auch echt an.
Anliegt, dass äh ja.
Auch, dass einem dann nicht mehr so viel Luft in die Augen äh gepustet wird oder unter die Brille oder wie auch immer.
Da gab's auch noch einen neuen Vorschlag, eine neue Initiative. Wir hatten ja letztes Mal so diverse ähm Zirokowit
Initiativen vorgestellt und um die Sache noch ein bisschen komplizierter und unüberschaubar zu machen, gibt's jetzt irgendwie auch noch eine No-Kovit,
Strategie
Und ich weiß nicht, hast du das äh verstanden, wo jetzt hier der Unterschied ist? Also ich habe so Interviews gesehen und die meinten so, ja, Zerokovic, das wäre ja ein Fehler, aber Noko wird das wäre ja total
total super äh und halt ich habe das so ein bisschen wahrgenommen, das ist im Wesentlichen der Unterschied ist, dass man irgendwie äh den Industriebereich nicht runterfährt.
Hast du das äh verstanden, was die damit äh.
Was hier so der Kern dieser Strategie sein soll.
Ehrlich gesagt nicht wirklich also am Ende des Tages.
Ist es auch eine Frage der Maßnahmenpriorisierung aber.
Da die beste Strategie ja ist erstmal so viel wie möglich zu machen, ist dann die Frage in welcher Reihenfolge man dann Dinge lockert.
Aber das Ziel kann in beiden Fällen aber nur sein extrem niedrige beherrschbare Quoten.
Und ich habe mir, glaube ich, die Zusammenfassung von Nokovic und Sirokovit.
Sogar mehrfach angeguckt, aber ja.
Keinen nennenswerten Unterschied feststellen können oder wie.
Man kann jetzt sagen, Nokovit ist so ein bisschen die,
freundlichere Variante von Sirokowit.
So habe ich es auch wahrgenommen.
Ja, wenn man schon irgendjemand muss ja das Geld verdienen. Also ja.
Darum muss ich ja auch jemand kümmern. Gut, mehr können wir dann wohl erstmal nicht zu sagen.
Dann ähm äußern wir uns doch lieber äh über andere Sachen. Ähm.
Es gibt ein ein neues Medikament.
Was eingekauft wurde, darüber ist äh auch so einiges drüber berichtet worden, dass es ein Antikörpermedikament.
Das hat also das Gesundheitsministerium beschlossen, dass das irgendwie in ja eine Größenordnung von zweihunderttausend Dosen,
gekauft wird und dann eben bei Krankenhäusern vorliegt. Das erscheint mir eine ganz sinnvolle Maßnahme zu sein. Also das sind diese sogenannten monoklonalen.
Antikörper. Das bedeutet, dass man also hier so medizinisch produzierte,
oder pharmakologisch produzierte Antikörper hat also quasi das, was die Immunantwort unter anderem
mitproduziert, ne? Das, was eben das Virus explizit angreift und quasi dieses Bike-Protein verklebt, damit es eben nicht mehr aktiv werden kann. Das ist ja das, was wir in den Blutbahnen haben wollen, unter anderem.
Also abgesehen von so T-Zellen und so weiter. Ähm aber was eben auch schon mal helfen kann und,
Es gibt halt jetzt dieses Medikament,
dem man Leuten, also das ist jetzt keine Pille oder so, sondern das ist das wird gespritzt, das muss man an Intravenös äh geben und es macht halt Sinn.
In dem Moment, wo man quasi entweder befürchtet, dass Leute sich demnächst infizieren oder eben eine Infektion in einem sehr, sehr frühen Stadium haben.
Jetzt wissen wir ja alle so Tests äh ja kommen in der Regel immer zu spät und äh wer weiß schon vorher, ob er überhaupt infiziert wird. Das ist hier eigentlich eher so diese typische Altenheimpflegeheimsituation,
Man hat einen Ausbruch.
In einem geschlossenen Bereich, wo eben viele volle Patienten, beziehungsweise betreute Personen äh sich aufhalten, ne? Also.
Typischer Fall, ein Pflegerin oder Pfleger oder eben Besucherinnen, Besucher,
Infektion ein, dann wird ein ja ein Mitarbeiter krank oder eben,
dem Fall dann vor allem halt ältere Leute, die dort gepflegt werden, wenn äh jemand in zirzig und wird dann krank,
so dass halt da die Alarmglocken läuten und sagen so oha alles klar das Virus ist auf jeden Fall im Haus,
Die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass ich das jetzt eben über die Mitarbeiter auch auf andere äh pflegende
gepflegte übertragen hat, ist relativ hoch, ja? Man kann quasi die Uhr danach stellen, bis es eben rumgeht und dann eben alle krank werden, dann mit den entsprechenden Gefährdungen für schwere Verläufe und Tod.
Und das wäre eben sozusagen der Moment, wo man sagt, okay, bring ihnen eine Antikörpermittel, dass halt dann die äh Leute breitflächig.
Quasi so so eine Art äh Quickimpung, ne? Die Antikörper werden direkt in die Blutbahn gebracht,
Und wenn halt das Virus dann äh auftaucht, dann hat der Körper schon mal was, womit er das bekämpfen kann,
Die verbleiben dann nicht ewig. Der Körper hat nicht gelernt, diese Antikörper selber zu produzieren. Das ist hal,
nicht vergleichbar mit einer tatsächlichen Immunantwort, die ja quasi das komplette System in Betrieb bringt und
unter anderem diese Antikörper produziert. Hier werden die Antikörper einfach so als Endergebnis,
beigemenkt, aber solange sie sich eben noch vergleichsweise frisch im Körper dann eben befinden
durch die Gabe äh können sie dann sich eben auch auf die Viren stürzen und damit halt unter Umständen eine Infektion oder zumindest einen schweren Verlauf,
verhindern. Das
erscheint mir eine ganz äh sinnvolle Sache zu sein und dafür ist halt mal Geld in die Hand genommen worden und ja mal gucken, ob das dann auch äh entsprechende Erfolge feiern kann, aber damit kann man halt unter Umständen verhindern, dass Leute sterben und das ist ja Sinn der ganzen Geschichte.
Bringt aber dann nichts mehr, wenn sagen bereits das Virus sich auf dem Höhepunkt seiner Ausbreitung befindet und schon äh in die Zellen eingedrungen ist, äh ja.
Richtig.
Genau, dafür ist es nicht gemacht, aber es ist halt für solche Situationen, wo es einfach absehbar ist, dass die Infektion sich nicht verhindern lässt und dann äh kann man halt zumindest auch schwere Verläufe verhindern. Im Idealfall.
Ich glaube Donald Trump ist damit auch behandelt worden.
Richtig. Genau, dem haben sie ja irgendwie alles gegeben und der hat unter Umständen auch davon profitiert, weil er halt relativ häufig regelmäßig getestet wurde und dann konnten sie halt früh sehen, aha, okay, hier passiert was und dann.
Ob das jetzt am Ende das der Wirkstoff ist, der geholfen hat, das weiß man nicht, die haben ihn ja irgendwie so ziemlich alles gegeben, was äh äh irgendwie bei drei nicht auf den Bäumen war.
Außer außer äh Bleiche und äh äh.
Hydrochloque, Hydroxyklorequeen. Ja. Ja, das äh ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, wie dieses Mittel eigentlich heißt. Ähm.
Aber es ist auch noch nicht zugelassen, oder? Bisher das Medikament richtig.
Das ist nicht zugelassen, aber.
Klar.
Das an, aber ist mit mit entsprechenden Notfallzulassung kann man das halt trotzdem machen.
Nutzenrisikoeinschätzung et cetera, dann geht sowas. Gut. Dann ähm.
Haben wir Feedback bekommen? Und zwar von Laura.
Laura hat sich geäußert zu unserer Diskussion.
Für rund um diese ganze Sequenzierung und hat das mal klargestellt.
Da eigentlich gerade tatsächlich abgeht und dass es dann doch noch ein bisschen anders ist als wir das dargestellt haben. Sie schreibt. Hallo, ich
freue mich jedes Wochenende über eine neue Folge Corona Wickly, wirklich schön, wie ihr die aktuelle Corona Lage siziert, danke dafür
Da ihr auch immer Feedback so schön vorbildlich in die Sendung einarbeitet, würde ich euch gerne auf eine Falschaussage hinweisen, die man euch nicht vorwerfen kann, aber unbedingt richtig stellen sollte. Der Hintergrund ist gleich auf mehreren Ebenen
interessant
dass die Labore jetzt verpflichtet seien, fünf Prozent ihrer Proben zu sequenzieren ist ein Mythos. Da hat Spahn auf einer Pressekonferenz Misterzählt, wurde von den Hauptstadtjournalisten so zitiert und seither geistert die Aussage durch die Medien und wird ständig wiederholt.
Man fragt sich, warum das
Bundesministerium für Gesundheit das nicht längst klargestellt hat. Vielleicht weil es den Politiker stark aussehen lässt, wenn er etwas anordnet. Na ja, darüber kann man nur spekulieren. Und man kann auch die Journalisten kritisieren, die sich nicht die Mühe gemacht haben, einfach mal in die Verordnung reinzugucken
Tatsache ist jedenfalls, dass die neue Verordnung allenfalls finanzielle Anreize für die Labore vorsieht, mehr zu sequenzieren und ihre Daten dann der Wissenschaftscommunity zur Verfügung stellen
Diese Meldung im Ärzteplatz, den Link findet ihr in den Shownotes.
Wesentlichen Punkte in der Verordnung gut zusammen, da heißt es unter anderem
Zitat, demnach können künftig
bis zu fünf Prozent aller per PCR positiv getesteten Proben einer vollgenommen Analyse unterzogen werden. Sollten die täglichen neuen Fektionen unter siebzigtausend pro Woche sinken, erhöht sich dieser zu untersuchende Anteil auf maximal
zehn Prozent der PCR positiven Proben.
Weiteres Zitat, eine Pflicht für Laborbetreiber, die Sequenzierung durchzuführen, gibt es dabei in der Verordnung nicht. Ne, also.
Ich weiß nicht ganz genau, ob wir das genauso äh formuliert haben, dass sie eine Verpflichtung vorliegt, aber das ist es nicht,
Äh drittes Zitat aus dem Artikel, die zur vollgenommenen Sequenzierung qualifizierten Laboratorien werden lediglich zur Übermittlung,
ihrer gefundenen Sequenzen verpflichtet. Sie dürfen zweihundertzwanzig Euro pro Probe mit der kassenärztlichen Vereinigung ihrer Region abrechnen, nachdem sie die Genomdaten psychonomisiert an das RKI gesendet haben,
Also das bedeutet so viel wie sie werden nicht verpflichtet es zu tun. Sie werden nur verpflichtet, dass wenn sie es tun, dass sie das dann auch übermitteln müssen,
und dann können sie es auch abrechnen und dann kriegen sie auch die Kohle dafür.
Okay, ich meine, ist trotzdem ein Anreiz, aber es ist natürlich was anderes, als dass sie jetzt alle verpflichtet werden, diese äh Analysen durchzuführen.
Warum das jetzt so formuliert ist, weiß ich nicht. Vermutlich kann man die auch gar nicht so äh verpflichten, äh rechtlich schon gar nicht und praktisch müssen die natürlich auch die Kapazitäten frei haben et cetera, ne,
Laura schreibt weiter, hierbei stellt sich allerdings noch die Frage der Infrastruk,
Die Daten sollen nämlich in einem einheitlichen Format auf einer gemeinsamen Plattform hochgeladen werden.
Beides existiert meines Wissens noch nicht und wir wissen ja, wie gut das mit dem Datenaustausch beim RKI klappt. In der letzten,
ALM Pressekonferenz, also das ist der größte Verband der Medizinlabore
haben die Leute jedenfalls schon angedeutet, dass sie sehr gespannt auf die Umsetzung sind und noch nicht so richtig wissen, was München genommen Sequen,
denn nun genau anstellen sollen, bevor sie Krohle kriegen. Aber das mal am Rande,
Auf der Pressekonferenz hat Spahn übrigens noch mehr Stoß über die Mutation von sich gegeben und unter anderem behauptet, dass bisher alle Infektionen bei Reiserückkehrern festgestellt worden seien. Das stimmte schon damals nicht,
jeder der die Berichterstattung zu dem Thema verfolgt hat, konnte das wissen. Dazu würde ich,
euch das Krautsourcing-Projekt von Cornelius Römer an Herz äh ans Herz legen, der eine ziemlich gute Übersicht geschaffen hat,
wo die Varianten schon überall aufgetaucht sind. Auch dieser Link natürlich in den Shownotes. Ich habe ihn neulich äh für Tonline äh mit ihm gesprochen.
Und die Daten als Karte aufbereitet, äh bisschen Eigenpromo an der Stelle, das äh seid ihr das seid ihr äh.
Überlassen. Dauer. Die Tabelle bietet zugegebenermaßen mehr Infos und ist aktueller. Es ist schon recht erstaunlich, dass ein Student mit Internetzugang es schafft, die Öffentlichkeit besser zu informieren, als das BMG.
Ja vielen Dank Laura für die ausführlichen Kommentare alle hier genannten Links wie gesagt in den äh Shownotes,
Wir stellen also fest, es wurden Dinge getan und angekündigt
Labor können jetzt mehr sequenzieren und vielleicht wenn es irgendwann mal eine Softwarelösung gibt, die funktioniert, dann können sie vielleicht diese Daten auch übermitteln und dann werden sie auch dafür bezahlt. Also das könnte noch ein bisschen dauern, bis wir da äh hinterherkommen. Hier zahlt sich halt
leider negativ aus, dass wir eben so eine Sequenzierungstradition und schon,
vor allem eine Automatisierung der Datenübermittlung
noch nicht etabliert haben. Na ja, so ist es.
Ja, angeblich ist aber auch irgendwie ein ganzer Schwung jetzt von Sequenzen aus Deutschland jetzt,
international zumindest veröffentlicht worden.
Not können die das ja gleich dann auf die internationalen Server hochladen, die Labore und dann äh.
Dem RKI einen Link schicken. Ähm.
Ja, aber auf jeden Fall deuten die vielen Pfunde jetzt, wo man angefangen hat, hinzugucken, findet man plötzlich auch die Motation überall.
Und ja wir haben ja schon vor Wochen äh äh gesagt, dass die Wahrscheinlichkeit äh dass,
ja schon unbemerkt eine ganze Menge an Infektionen durch,
neuen Montation stattfinden in Deutschland scheint sich jetzt zu bestätigen. Ja, also wir waren damals darauf gekommen, dass ungefähr sagen bis zu dreihundert Fälle pro Tag äh.
Bereits das.
B eins eins sieben Virus sein könnten äh und wir trotzdem einen Monat brauchen würden, um das zu bemerken bei unserer äh bisherigen.
Kinosequenziererei, ja? Äh und ja jetzt sieht man halt schon, dass es jetzt plötzlich,
auftaucht in Zusammenhängen, wo man nicht mehr genau weiß, wo es denn jetzt herkommt, wo also jetzt der Zusammenhang mit Reiserückkehrern der unmittelbare gar nicht mehr da ist.
Anderen Reisenden, also wenn davon ausgehen, es ist in the Wild.
Ja, also B eins eins sieben ist schon zweihundert Mal in Deutschland gefunden worden und äh ja
das äh können wir glaube ich vergessen, dass dass wir da in irgendeiner Form eine Chance haben, dass das zu Container, also vielleicht vielleicht kann man Schlimmeres äh verhindern, aber bestimmt nicht verhindern, dass es sich hier überhaupt irgendwie breit macht.
Die äh ja die ich hab noch nicht so den Eindruck, dass man sich schon komplett einig sind wie,
äh gefährlich äh das sind jetzt am Ende äh wirklich ist. Ich warte immer noch so ein bisschen auf die Bestätigung ähm dieser ursprünglichen Thesen der höheren Verbreitung, aber das werden wir ja offensichtlich so in den nächsten paar Wochen dann auch mal sehen können.
Ja gut, was was ziemlich, also was für mich äh ziemlich überzeugend und klar ist, ist, dass äh ja,
du um dir B eins eins sieben zu holen du ja ein Drittel.
Hälfte weniger Kontakte brauchst als für die normale Variante, so das ist,
also die vierzig Prozent von denen da immer die Rede sind, sind da da gibt's genügend Zahlenbelege für mittlerweile.
Dass das so ist was, was halt noch nicht ganz klar ist, ist.
Irgendeine der Varianten schwierigere Verläufe äh mit sich bringt. Das sieht wohl nicht so aus.
Auch so das tendenziell ja äh Montation bevorzugt äh werden.
Ähm sich sich auch leichter durchsetzen, die nicht.
So schädlich sind, die halt nicht so viel Symptome äh machen, die die Leute nicht davon abhalten aus dem Haus zu gehen oder äh ja ähm insofern kann man sagen.
Dass Mutation in der Regel hin zu leichterer Übertrag,
stattfinden tun sie natürlich in alle Richtungen, wenn man sozusagen das als Vektor betrachtet, aber ja äh dann dann durchsetzen. Ja und dann kommt natürlich jetzt auch,
mit insbesondere der der südafrikanischen Variante. Ja, das Problem.
Der im geringeren Wirksamkeit der bisherigen Impfungen.
Ja, das haben wir letzte Woche schon angesprochen.
Dann lass uns mal zu den Impfungen äh vorankommen, zum Thema Impfung in Deutschland lässt sich nicht viel sagen.
Es geht weiterhin langsam voran, also in den letzten Tagen ist keine nennenswerte Steigerung der Impfgeschwindigkeit äh zu verzeichnen gewesen. Also so im Schnitt ähm ist es äh.
Ja wo liegen wir so jetzt ungefähr so um die neunzig.
Neunzigtausend.
Neunzig fünfundneunzigtausend Impfungen pro Tag im Schnitt, so wie letzte Woche über.
Ich schaue jetzt einfach auf die, die Übersicht auf Auerwald in Data, ne? Also das äh die zählen halt irgendwie Singledosis so.
Unterscheiden glaube ich nicht zwischen erster und zweiter, sondern es ist sozusagen die Insumme rausgegebenen. Aber die eigentliche Infraktivität selber äh ist zumindest nicht deutlich angestiegen. Sie ist zwar jetzt im letzten Monat,
Im Prinzip kontinuierlich angestiegen, so, aber derzeit gibt's da keine Beschleunigung groß in dem ganzen Geschehen.
Ja, also kann sagen ja.
In der letzten Woche zumindest ist die Zahl im wesentlichen konstant geblieben letzten ja zehn fast letzten zehn Tage hat sich da äh nicht viel bewegt.
Außer, dass man eben begonnen hat, zwei Impfungen durchzuführen.
Genau, aber das war jetzt zu erwarten, da sind ja die äh entsprechenden Dosen zurückgelegt worden dafür. Das findet halt einfach statt. Aber was wir halt eigentlich brauchen, ist eine Verzehnfachung dieser Impfaktivität und davon sind wir noch weit entfernt.
Ja mindestens eher eigentlich eine im Moment eine Verzwanzigfachung, wenn wir auf das Niveau von Israel äh äh kommen.
Möchten und da wir ja aber das bei uns so langsam losgeht, müssten wir das, was wir jetzt.
Fragen, die langsame Anlaufphase auch irgendwann kompensieren, das heißt, wir müssten eigentlich äh auf das dreißig oder vierzigfache äh kommen,
pro Tag, also wir müssten ungefähr äh.
Jeden Tag eher ein bis zwei Millionen Impfungen durchführen oder.
Ja äh gut die einen wie eher zwei bis drei Millionen Impfungen durchführen pro Tag.
Tja, aber dafür haben wir die äh entsprechenden Mengen einfach derzeit nicht, wie es aussieht,
Schauen wir nochmal nach Israel, da bleibt's ja spannend. Wir hatten ja letzte Woche schon gesagt, da müssten ja demnächst jetzt mal Ergebnisse zu sehen sein, jetzt wo
die ähm Impfquote so hoch ist. Also derzeit sieht es so aus, dass im im.
Sechzig, siebzig, was war das? Nee, siebzig Plus hat irgendwie schon zu fünfundsiebzig Prozent. Die zweite Dosis erhalten. Stand heute.
Daraus lässt sich leider nicht so ohne Weiteres ablesen, wie lange das zurückliegt, weil wir wissen ja alle, erst nach der zweiten Dosis und dann nochmal nach zwei Wochen, dann ist in der Regel,
sagen wir mal im Schnitt dann auf jeden Fall ähm bei allen die maximale Immunisierung, die eben zu erreichen ist auch wirklich erreicht,
und ab dann sollte man eben auch entsprechende Auswirkungen sehen. Ähm.
Da wir immer noch keine klaren Erkenntnisse darüber haben, ob der Bayerntisch,
Impfstoff auch tatsächlich Infektionen,
nachhaltig verhindern kann, ja? Kann's durchaus sein, dass Leute noch positiv getestet werden,
es sollte sich dann eben zumindest die Zahl der Krankenhauseinlieferungen und es sollte sich dann natürlich auch die Zahl,
Toten,
entsprechend reduzieren und im Idealfall dann auch gegen null gehen. Es gibt aber jetzt vorab Informationen und zwar gibt's eine Auswertung der.
Impfung von sechzig Jahre und älter Altersgruppe.
Da hat man dann mal geschaut, wie es denn mit äh Krankenhauseinlieferungen aussieht. Bei Leuten, die innerhalb der letzten drei Wochen nach der ersten, also die innerhalb
Innerhalb von innerhalb von drei Wochen nach der ersten Impfung.
Ab der ersten Impfung. Ab genau, nicht innerhalb ab. So, also nochmal, äh habe mich ein bisschen bekloppt ausgedrückt. Also äh Sechzigjährige oder Elter,
die geimpft wurden, hat sich nach drei Wochen nach dieser äh Änderung, nach dieser Impfung,
was geändert bei der Einlieferung in Krankenhäuser. Hospitalisierung, wie man so schön sagt.
Und kurze Antwort, ja, hat sich was getan und zwar sind es sechzig Prozent weniger.
Nicht hundert Prozent, nicht achtzig Prozent, aber immerhin sechzig Prozent, ne? Nochmal aufgepasst nach der ersten Impfung.
Das ist ungefähr der Zeitpunkt, wo man dann die zweite Impfung bekommt. Ich glaube, der Zeitpunkt, wo sie das jetzt äh ausgewertet haben, war tatsächlich ein oder zwei Tage nach der zweiten Impfung. Die dann selber ja auch nochmal zwei Wochen braucht, eben bis sie eben wirklich durchschlägt,
Was kann man der Zahl jetzt entnehmen? Also irgendwas wirkt,
Das lässt sich glaube ich äh schon mal deutlich sagen. Also wenn sechzig Prozent weniger ins Krankenhaus müssen, dann dann tut sich definitiv da was, ja. Das ist aber jetzt
eine Zahl, die uns nicht wirklich äh weiterbringt, weil wir brauchen halt äh was tut sich dann zwei Wochen später nochmal.
Ja, wobei, wie gesagt, da ja jetzt.
Wir diese hohen Zweitdosenrate haben in Israel äh können wir sagen äh dass äh zumindest.
Diese sechzig Prozent auf alle, die dort ihre zweite Impfung erhalten haben, man im Prinzip äh äh davon ausgehen kann, dass das eigentlich.
Jetzt auf ja äh fünfundsiebzig Prozent,
älteren Bevölkerung zutreffen müsste.
So aber jetzt.
Ein Blick auf die Zahlen und zwar sowohl, was jetzt die schweren Verläufe oder Hospitalisierungen äh äh angeht.
Als auch die Zahl der Neuinfektionen, als auch die Zahl der Toten sieht man nur einen sehr moderaten Rückgang in Israel bisher,
bis zum heutigen Tag. Und das äh passt für mich jetzt.
Nicht so ganz zusammen, ist jetzt sicherlich auch kein unauflösbarer Widerspruch.
Aber so eine so richtig eine Erklärung dafür habe ich jetzt nicht. Warum,
dass sich in den Gesamtzahlen nicht.
Äh auswirkt, eine Möglichkeit könnte sein, dass.
Dafür jetzt, weil man das Gefühl hat, oh, mit dem Impfen geht das jetzt so stark äh äh so gut voran, äh dass die Leute jetzt weniger anfangen aufzupassen und,
quasi der Schutz, der bei den Älteren schon da ist jetzt durch ja Nachlässigkeit bei den Jüngeren,
wieder kompensiert wird, das könnte auch sein. Passt's natürlich, aber dann wiederum nicht zu,
der Zahl der schweren Verläufe und der Zahl der Toten, die noch nach wie vor so hoch sind so. Also irgendwas äh,
passt da nicht zusammen für mich und äh wenn man jetzt das weiter im Auge behalten und gucken, wie sich das vielleicht auflöst.
Ja gut, ich meine die Zahl der Toten geht ja nun auch wirklich auf Fälle zurück, die halt auch unter Umständen vier, fünf, sechs Wochen äh her sind, ne? Also ich glaube mit der,
Bei den Toten muss man wirklich jetzt noch warten. So, aber so.
Zero ist natürlich jetzt wirklich so das Erste, was passiert und äh schlimmere Konsequenzen andeutet. Von daher ist das durchaus schon mal eine ganz optimistische Zahl, finde ich.
Ja, wir werden.
Aber wir können's einfach zu diesem Zeitpunkt noch nicht noch nicht wirklich bewerten. Das muss man jetzt auch mal sagen. Das sind Anzeichen, da tut sich irgendwas,
wissen noch nicht, in welchem Maße sich da was tut. Man kann aber auf jeden Fall sagen, die,
Impfung bringen Bewegung ins Spiel.
Ja, es ist noch keine Bewegung, die jetzt äh sich insgesamt in allen Zahlen deutlich äh niederschlägt, aber es hat einen Einfluss.
Ja. Also man kann aber auch definitiv festhalten, dass in dem Moment selbst wenn du fünfzig Prozent deiner Bevölkerung.
Durchgeimpft hast, so hat das erstmal noch keine wirklich spürbaren Auswirkungen auf deine Zahlen.
Pso.
Ja gut, aber bei fünfzig Prozent sind sie ja auch noch nicht, ne.
Ja
Also sie haben jetzt fünfzig Prozent, haben den haben die äh erste Impfung erhalten,
Oder? Also mal, was haben wir hier? Total Population? Ne, stimmt überhaupt nicht. Also hier laut dem Original-Dashboard in Israel.
First ist fünfunddreißig und Zeckendos ist achtzehn. Komme ich aber gar nicht auf die fünfzig Prozent, die ich woanders sehe.
Mehr fünfzig Prozent sagen Impfungen äh äh Dosen, Dosen auf.
Sozusagen beides zusammen.
Also tatsächlich sind derzeit nur achtzehn Komma sieben Prozent in Israel der Bevölkerung, achtzehn Komma sieben Prozent haben die zweite Dosis erhalten.
Das ist der Stand heute. Und wenn ich jetzt mal zwei Wochen äh zurückgehe, also was haben wir hier? Dreißig, dann müssten wir ja mal bis zum sechzehnten zurückgehen.
Dann haben wir quasi ein Stand von nur drei Komma fünf Prozent die die zweite Dosis bekommen haben. Ne, also nur nur drei Komma fünf Prozent der Bevölkerung.
Sind jetzt an so einem Punkt, wo man sagen kann, du hast jetzt die volle Maximalmögliche,
den Impfstoff erreicht. Kein Wunder, dass sich das noch nicht groß widerspiegelt.
Ja
aber man hätte sich jetzt mehr erhofft oder vielleicht mehr erwartet jetzt bei einem reinen Blick auf wie viel äh und wie schnell äh dort geimpft wird und.
Die Lehre daraus ist, äh selbst wenn man so schnell impft, wenn man zwanzig Mal so schnell empf,
alles noch seine Zeit.
Das stimmt schon. Aber na ja, aber dies, das das geht jetzt eben voran, ne? Also
wenn man jetzt mal sagt angenommen wir würden uns jetzt in einer Woche wieder darüber unterhalten und dann schauen dann auf Israel.
Dann haben wir es immerhin schon mit äh neun Komma fünf Prozent der Bevölkerung zu tun.
Ja und so weiter.
Also es sollten das mal in zwei bis vier Wochen äh äh auf jeden Fall äh uns wieder anschauen,
ob sich, ich sage mal, in zwei Wochen, wenn sich was getan hat, in vier Wochen, wenn sich bis dahin noch nichts getan hat, wäre beides äh glaube ich dann eine Meldung.
Genau und wenn sie sich in sich in vier Wochen dann nichts getan hat, dann will ich mein Geld zurück.
Ich ich.
Also mal echt Israel. Los.
Äh wir verlinken mal dieses Data-Dashboard, auf das wir jetzt hier gerade blicken. Das ist allein schon geil, weil sowas hätte ich ja gerne für Deutschland, aber haben wir natürlich nicht
gar keine Frage. Wir haben also zwar auch irgendwie so ein komisches Dashboard, aber das ist einfach überhaupt gar kein Vergleich. Was man hier für eine Detailtiefe so auf den ersten Blick bekommt. Das ist dann alles auf hebräisch,
Da müsst ihr euer äh Hebräierschlexikon wieder rausholen. Nee, Quatsch braucht ihr nicht machen. Schickt das hier irgendwie durch Google Translade und dann äh wird das schon ganz brauchbar wiedergegeben.
Ja, wobei fieserweise Google Translate kannst du keine Webseiten mehr übersetzen lassen. Die wollen die Leute nämlich jetzt zu Chrome äh zwingen und dann die dort,
eingebaute in Anführungsstrichen Übersetzungsfunktionen dafür nutzen.
So ist das. Ist äh allerdings bei Safari jetzt auch nicht anders.
Mal gucken, ich probier's mal damit, ob das auch funktioniert. Äh wird mir hier auch eine Übersetzung angeboten. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob die überhaupt schon hebräisch können.
Da liegt jetzt erstmal die Seite gar nicht. Na ja egal, das werden wir, könnt ihr dann selber ausprobieren. Wir machen jetzt erstmal weiter mit dem nächsten Thema. Denn wir müssen ja auch über Impfstoffen, Impfstoffe reden.
Das ist ja auch äh sehr interessant und äh Nimmstoffe war vor allem ganz viele haben, aber.
Teilweise geht es dann doch noch ein bisschen,
langsam zu. Also ähm wir hatten jetzt äh erstmal gute Nachricht, eine neue Zulassung,
eines Impfstoffs, nämlich das Astro Astra Seneka Augsford University Impfstoffs
Der ist jetzt offiziell zugelassen worden von der European Medical Association. Das war der lang erwartete Test, der jetzt Ende Januar stattgefunden hat. Sprich, die haben halt die Unterlagen eingereicht, die haben sich das alles angeschaut und dann gesagt so hm okay
sieht ja eigentlich ganz gut aus. Ähm, wir lassen das jetzt mal zu
Es gibt da allerdings noch so ein paar offene Fragen. Also es
ähm also zur Erinnerung, das ist jetzt dieser Impfstoff, der nicht so sehr gekühlt werden muss, der ähm auf äh modifizierten Adenovieren, die sich nicht mehr reproduzieren können, basiert und natürlich dann auch gegen dieses Bike-Protein vorgeht.
Die Empfehlung lautet jetzt, dass dieser Impfstoff geeignet ist für Leute von achtzehn bis fünfundfünfzig Jahren. Das war jetzt zumindest die Aussage der EMA, warum? Es gab insgesamt vier klinische Überprüfungen,
unter anderem in UK, in Brasilien und in Südafrika. Wobei die Studien aus Südafrika von der EMA überhaupt gar nicht erst herangezogen wurden, weil's da zu wenig Fälle gab, ne? Aber es gab im Leben noch drei übrig
Und ähm da haben dann insgesamt vierundzwanzigtausend Teilnehmer äh mitgemacht. Das ist,
auch ganz ordentlich, ist nicht ganz so viel wie jetzt bei Björn Tech und bei moderner, die ja gleich mit zweiunddreißig den vierzigtausend unterwegs war. Aber das ist immer noch, das muss man mal dazu sagen. Immer noch sehr viel mehr als das üblicherweise bei Impfstoffen bei anderen,
der Fall war oder bei anderen Infektionen der Fall war.
Ja, Effizienz ist jetzt allerdings nicht wie die RM RNA äh Stoffe bei fünfundneunzig Prozent, sondern äh bei neunundfünfzig Komma fünf, also knapp sechzig Prozent,
Und ähm ja da die meisten Teilnehmer irgendwo zwischen achtzehn und fünfundfünfzig Jahre alt waren, hat man eben
ja jetzt keine Empfehlung für ältere Leute gemacht und einfach gesagt, ja, nee, bleib mal bei achtzehn bis fünfundfünfzig
die äh Stico in Deutschland, also die ständige Impfkommission, die ja darüber entscheidet, wie das so in Deutschland gehandhabt werden soll
hat da noch ein bisschen mehr Flexibilität drin gesehen und hat gesagt na ja wir würden das jetzt auch bis fünfundsechzig empfehlen,
Das ist dann sozusagen eine Frage, wie du die Zahlen interpretierst und liest, denn ähm,
ist jetzt nicht so, dass jetzt alle den Eindruck hätten, dass da auf jeden Fall irgendwas eingebrochen ist. Es ist halt nur so, man hat halt nicht genug Teilnehmer gehabt. Aber man hat schon gesehen, dass auch der Astra Sinnika-Impfstoff,
die entsprechende Immunantwort hat, ja? Es man
konnte eben bloß dann in diesen doppelten Tests eben nicht genug Fälle haben, um wirklich verlässlich da eine Zahl produzieren zu können. Und auf Basis der Erfahrung, die man eben jetzt mit anderen Impfstoffen schon hat
geht man im Allgemeinen davon aus, dass das vermutlich auch bei älteren Leuten dann auch entsprechend wirkt, nur ähm.
Man spricht jetzt eben noch keine Empfehlung aus. Ne, das Gleiche
gilt dann eben auch für Jugendliche, da gibt's dann halt erst ab achtzehn los. Was wird also jetzt passieren? Es wird jetzt von der Europäischen Kommission eine sogenannte Conditional Marketing Austriasation und so,
CMA ausgesprochen, damit es dann eben auch eingekauft bestellt
unverteilt und verimpft werden kann in der EU.
Das Gute an dem ähm Impfstoff ist, also vielleicht nochmal ein Wort zu dieser Effizienz, ne? Sechzig Prozent, da denkt man sich so, ja, was ist das denn für einen Supermarkt äh Impfstoff hier?
Das ist immer noch mehr als man bei anderen erfolgreichen Impfstoffen zum Beispiel gegen Masern und so gesehen hat. Sechzig Prozent ist ein sehr guter Wert, ja?
Klar, jetzt denkt man sich so, okay, jetzt werde ich damit geimpft, dann habe ich sozusagen nur so eine sechzig Prozent Chance äh dem Ganzen zu entgehen.
So kann man das wahrscheinlich lesen, ne? Bin mal gespannt ähm was das jetzt so auslöst, wenn so ein,
Wissen darum gibt es mehrere Impfstoffe unterwegs sind und der eine verspricht irgendwie fünfzig Prozent mehr Erfolg zu haben als der andere.
Na ja, wir hatten das ja mal kurz thematisiert vor einigen äh Sendungen weiß ich noch, äh gesagt haben, hm ähm.
Ja äh ich würde glaube ich mich trotzdem auch mit dem.
Astra Senika im Stoff impfen lassen, wenn der verfügbar wäre und äh ich auf den anderen länger warten müsste, so ja, der entfaltet seinen Nutzen und äh.
Es hilft also insofern.
Ja, aber es ist natürlich schon ja, ich weiß gar nicht, ob's die Situation überhaupt in anderen Zusammenhängen äh gab und es ja.
Es ist natürlich auch so dann die die Frage, ob man an irgendeinem Punkt, wenn.
Die hocheffizienten Impfstoffe verfügbar sind, ob das überhaupt ethisch vertretbar sind, ist, dann.
Einen sechzig Prozent statt, einen neunzig Prozent äh oder dreiundneunzig Prozent Impfstoff zu nehmen.
Unter, würde ich sagen äh normaler Situation, also nicht Mangelsituation hätte wahrscheinlich dieser andere Impfstoff am Markt keine guten Chancen.
Denke ich mal, zumindest nicht in westlichen Ländern. So fällt als Billigimpfstoff für die dritte Welt oder so.
Aber das ist er ja eigentlich auch nicht, oder? So, als wäre toll im Stoff. Oder wie teuer war der Produ.
Nein, nein, der ist sehr günstig. Also der.
Ach das war der fünfzig Cent Impfstoff.
Ja also ich würde mal sagen so äh fünf fünf bis zehn Prozent der Kosten, die du jetzt bei den MRNA
Impfstoffen siehst. Also ich habe da sehr unterschiedliche Darstellungen gesehen, ob man die jetzt für fünfzig Cent kriegt oder einen Dollar. Aber es ist sozusagen in dem, in dem Bereich, ne,
Von daher sehr günstig und im Prinzip eben auch mit bereits etablierten Produktionsmethoden breitbandig herstellbar, der wird dann auch in Indien äh enorm zum Einsatz kommen
welche Rolle der jetzt hier spielen wird ähm ist eine gute Frage. Man muss halt sagen
er ist günstig, das ist ein Vorteil, der andere ist, er braucht halt keine aufwendige Kühlung. Das heißt,
Das ist jetzt ein Impfstoff, der auch an der Hausärzte ausgegeben werden könnte. So wie man das eben auch mit der Grippeimpfung macht. Das heißt, du könntest jetzt,
Jenseits der Impfzentren auch Hausärzte mit diesem Impfstoff ausrüsten.
Leute dort vor Ort bei den Hausärzten impfen lassen, womit du natürlich nochmal einen ganz anderen Riech hast, ne, weil der muss nicht aufwendig gekühlt werden, der kann einfach da im normalen Kühlschrank bleiben und hält lang genug.
Passt natürlich gerade wie Faust aufs Auge zu unserer Impfstrategie. Ähm,
so äh wo ja die Untersechzigjährigen erst ab Sommer eigentlich dran wären. Bin gespannt, wie sie,
das jetzt äh zusammenbringen, aber ja, Abgabe über Hausärzte an alle, die wollen, könnte dann wahrscheinlich,
so der richtige Weg sein. Stellt sich das Interesse dann auch bei dem Impfstoff dann bisschen in Grenzen, weil die Leute sich denken, ah nee, warte ich mal lieber auf den guten äh Impfstoff, kann ich mir gut vorstellen. Aber,
ja aber.
Das Pferd wäre jetzt sozusagen so unsere Altersklasse, ne? Und äh das heißt ja jetzt sozusagen die Wahl, ne?
Das ist wirklich eine interessante äh äh interessante Frage, was da so psychisch äh beim so abgeht, ne.
Aber auch sozusagen interessante Frage, wie denn jetzt ja die Politik denn damit umgehen wird, weil im Moment,
passt die Empfehlung der Impfkommission äh hinsichtlich äh äh ja nicht zur Strategie,
nicht zu Impfstrategie der Bundesregierung.
Ja gut, ne, ich ich meine, wenn's halt für die anderen Altersklassen keine Impfstoffe gibt
So, ja, also wenn der da nicht taucht, dann kann man den natürlich für die anderen nehmen. Also es wäre jetzt im Prinzip die Möglichkeit, dann Level vorzuziehen und sagen, okay, du bist jünger als fünfundsechzig, äh da hätten wir was beim Hausarzt so,
nimmt auch das.
Oder äh es wird ein spezielles Impfzentrum geben, dass dann halt den Impfstoff verimpft, das,
ist ja bisher glaube ich auch so, dass ich glaube bisher in Deutschland immer äh ein Impfzentrum immer nur ein eine Art von Impfstoff äh verimpft.
Na gut, das müssen wir äh abwarten, das gibt ja derzeit noch viel Schreierei zwischen Astra Senika und der EU bezüglich der zugesag
Lieferung, da gab's halt ursprünglich mal Abnahmeverpflichtungen und die EU ja auch gerne eingehen würde, würde aber Astra Sinnica spricht von Produktionsproblemen,
Das Plan halt gerade andere äh alle, ne? Also Pfizer kann nicht liefern, weil sie ihre Produktionskapazitäten grade umstellen. Äh dasselbe spielt sich auch gerade bei moderner ab. Das
ist natürlich blöd, aber hatte einfach was damit zu tun, dass sie eben,
Gerade ein Ramp-Up machen, um eben dann noch mehr äh herstellen zu können. Das wird also auf jeden Fall nochmal so eine Delle sein.
Wobei mir das irgendwie das kommt mir ehrlich gesagt.
Auch nicht ganz koscher vor. So, diese Ramp.
Geschichte. Ich mag mich da täuschen, ich habe da keinerlei Insiderinformationen, keine konkreten Informationen, aber.
Wenn ich jetzt Produktion ausbauen will, ja.
Dann baue ich doch nicht irgendwie meine.
Alte Anlage ab so und nehmen die erstmal außer Betrieb mitten in einer Pandimie. Das erscheint mir irgendwie.
Unlogisch äh zu sein. Also wenn sagen einfach nur der Grund ist, dass man
die Kapazität ausweiten will, äh normalerweise, ich meine,
mangelt ja jetzt sicherlich nicht an Gewerbefläche äh für für so
etwas, ja? Äh klar, ich kann mir da, ich kann mir da alles Mögliche vorstellen, aber ich habe das Gefühl, dass wir da bestenfalls die halbe Wahrheit,
äh Wissen an an der St.
Ich will mich da jetzt ein paar ich will mich da jetzt überhaupt nicht an irgendwelchen Spekulationen beteiligen. Es ist ja durchaus möglich, dass sie auch
einem Standort die Kapazität erhöhen. Und um neue Maschinen reinzubringen, die einfach dasselbe in der zehn oder zwanzigfachen Geschwindigkeit machen, musst du halt auch mal eine andere Maschine für eine Woche abstellen.
Weil du musst sie dann wegtragen
und äh durch eine andere ersetzen. Das ist halt ich äh für absolut nachvollbiere, nachvollziehbares Szenario und.
Da tun wir uns jetzt auch keinen Gefallen, hier irgendwas äh zu formulieren. Wir werden sehen, wie sich das entwickelt und ähm,
Das mögen im Hintergrund auch Verteilungskämpfe sein, weil alle gerade natürlich danach schreien.
Also was ich mir eher vorstellen kann, also das für mich logischer wäre
ist, äh, dass das so sagen bis dass man das macht, aber dass das sozusagen schon eher sagen,
vorgeschoben äh ist, weil es an irgendwelchen anderen
Dingen mangelt, weil man vielleicht nicht die Vorprodukte in der nötigen Menge gerade hat und sich
dann äh vielleicht
auch, ja, weiß ich nicht, bestimmte Maschinen vielleicht nicht betreibt oder äh dass man bestimmte Prozesse nicht fahren kann, weil da die Mittel äh oder Verbrauchsmaterialien fehlen und so. Also äh
ja, wie gesagt, alles reine Spekulation, aber aber das, das, was sagen, äh.
Nur sagen, es erscheint mir nicht plausibel, äh dass man nur um etwas aufzurüsten man die Produktion für Wochen
runterfahren.
Sterdis erscheint mir aus dem Wissen, wie ich das eigentlich, also aus meinen Produktions äh äh Kenntnissen äh so kommt mir das.
Vielleicht ist es ja auch, ja, also kann alles sein, falls ihr da Feedback für uns habt, dann lasst uns das bitte äh wissen. Vielleicht ist es auch einfach so, wir sind einfach so gewöhnt als erste Welt dann auch immer alles zu kriegen, was wir haben wollen,
Weißt du? Aber vielleicht gibt's da auch eine nullte Welt, die gerade einfach mehr Gull auf dem Tisch liegt. Und da haben wir dann das Nachsehen. Also.
Impft auch mehr. Als Deutschland.
Ja. Ja, Deutschland ist auch nicht mehr das, was es mal war.
Nö. Ja, dann noch äh ein kleines äh News,
zu Kiowak, die ist ja auch eine deutsche äh Firma, die angekündigt hat, noch ein ja, nahe im Stoff äh auf den Markt zu bringen. Das zieht sich äh wohl noch so ein bisschen. Allerdings gab's so ein kleines League aus dem Vertrag, was die EU
geschlossen hat
Und das äh hat nochmal so paar interessante politische Diskussionen im Nachgang, denn in diesem Vertrag steht drin, dass die,
kostenlose Weitergabe von Impfstoffen an Drittländer sollte man was übrig haben, nicht erlaubt ist. Es sei denn, das Unternehmen stimmt im Explizit nochmal zu.
Vielleicht und Seconds gar nicht so überraschend, ja? Kann man natürlich jetzt rumskandalisieren, aber ähm im Kern bedeutet das halt einfach, wir wollen, dass ihr, dass ihr die Menge, die ihr zugesagt habt, dass ihr die abnehmt.
Ja, dass wenn ihr sie nicht braucht, dass es nicht,
uns die Märkte woanders wieder kaputt macht. Und sieht auch selber zu, was ihr damit macht.
Gut. Am Ende des Tages äh.
Ist es alles eine Kostenfrage äh auch, so es sind ich würde mal sagen, ich finde diese Klausel jetzt für sich genommen jetzt nicht so besonders.
Skandalös ähm das ist immer eine Frage na was hätte,
es mehr gekostet, wenn die EU ähm,
die kostenlose Weitergabe von Impfstoffen mitvereinbart hätte, ganz offensichtlich bestand kein Interesse daran
dafür mehr Geld auf den Tisch zu legen, sodass man sich halt überlegt hat, ja schmeißt man im Zweifelsfall halt lieber weg.
Als dass man äh mehr dafür bezahlt, dass man ihn dann verschenken darf. Ich meine erstmal aus EU-Sicht.
Äh ja eine eine vernünftige die die Frage ist natürlich.
Was halt kostenlose Weitergabe bedeutet und ob auch der subventionierte Weiterverkauf oder Weiterverkauf dann zu einem niedrigeren Preis äh davon auch betroffen ist, weiß ich nicht äh,
aber äh ja ich find's jetzt nicht äh so den den.
Skandal, äh den den Großen. Äh am Ende müssten sie alle kalkulieren irgendwie. Ende müssten ja alle ihre Kosten äh äh wieder äh reingespielt kriegen.
Wo ist nicht so gut gelaufen ist mit dem Corona Impfschoff ist bei der Firma Merk,
hat nämlich jetzt ihre Entwicklung ihres Corona Impfstoffs eingestellt
Ja, also sie haben selber einen Impfstoff in Entwicklungen gehabt und haben den durch äh ihre ersten Phasen durchgebracht und ich glaube schon in Phase eins. Ist das jetzt gescheitert,
Ich weiß nicht ganz genau, wie der jetzt technisch aufgebaut war auf jeden Fall äh zeigt sich auch Firmen, die auch durchaus,
Erfahrung haben, also die machen Masernimpfstoffe zum Beispiel
haben dann nicht unbedingt immer den richtigen Ansatz für Impfstoffe in anderen Feldern und die haben halt jetzt ihre Impfstoffentwicklung eingestellt, weil sie halt jetzt zu diesem Zeitpunkt entweder über keinen neuen Ansatz verfügen oder zumindest geht's überhaupt
auch auf dem Markt keinerlei Möglichkeiten mehr sehen an den äh jetzt äh aktuellen Platzhirschen vorbeizukommen und dann irgendeiner Form nennenswert noch äh Geld zu machen, beziehungsweise von Firmen oder von Ländern
noch Verträge abgeschlossen bekommen oder angeboten bekommen, die äh die Weiterentwicklung auch sichern könnten.
Ich glaube der Hauptgrund, wenn ich mich recht in Sinne war, aber äh vor allem eine zu niedrige wirksam.
Ja klar, also der, an dem sie jetzt arbeiten, aber sie werden halt jetzt auch keinen anderen äh Ansatz wählen, das ist das, was ich sage, ne. Tja, so kann's laufen.
Ja. Weil es sind ja äh waren da nicht irgendwie so an die hundert Impfstoffe oder so weltweit eigentlich in in Entwicklung.
Gut am Ende wäre zwar wird's wahrscheinlich 'ne Hand voll sein, die dann überleben und natürlich irgendwann bist du natürlich zu spät irgendwann musst du,
entweder hast du einen Impfstoff, der genauso gut ist wie ein anderer, aber nur ein Bruchteil äh so viel kostet,
so oder einfache Handhabbar ist, wo äh ja oder du hast dann.
Spezielle Impfstoffe, die dann für bestimmte Gruppen auch geeignet sind, verdienen anderer Impfstoff äh nicht geeignet ist, wie, weil sie nicht schwangere oder Kinder, so denke ich mal, wird sich der Markt dann irgendwann,
strukturieren. Ja.
Na ja, also es kommen ja jetzt noch, es kommen ja jetzt noch ein paar andere äh Impfstoffe mit auf den Markt, die noch eine Rolle spielen werden von Johnson und Johnson. Der hat wohl relativ
brauchbare äh Effizienz nachgewiesen in den Trials, die derzeit laufen und Novawax hat auch noch einen am Start. Also das sind so die die nächsten, die kommen
heute kann ich nicht so richtig was sagen zu den chinesischen Impfstoffen, da gab's irgendwie einige Zweifel an der Wirksamkeit, ähm
ähnlich äh habe ich auch noch keine verlässlichen Ergebnisse gesehen jetzt mit Gamalea, diesem Sputnik fünf im Stoff aus äh Russland,
das müssen wir nochmal äh genauer beobachten.
Erstaunlich ruhig geworden, um diese beiden Impfstoffe, die ja so die ersten waren eigentlich.
Über die geredet wurde oder die.
Äh im im Try waren, aber ja, vielleicht ist das auch unsere äh West äh zentrierte Betrachtungsweise, keine Ahnung.
Na ja, aber auf jeden Fall zeigt sich, dass der Biontech und die moderner Impfstoffe derzeit so ein bisschen die Krone aufhaben und sicherlich wenn wir am Ende zu den meist verimpften,
in Stoffen gehören werden, wenn das so weiter geht.
Ja, das bringt uns so ein bisschen äh ans Ende der Sendung und da kann man dann vielleicht auch nochmal ein bisschen über das Ende äh der Pandemie äh sprechen
Und äh ganz passend dazu hat äh das Mylab auch ein neues Video gedroppt. Du hast es dir ja schon in Gänze angeschaut. Ich musste leider,
nach ein paar Minuten abbrechen, was kannst du mir denn darüber berichten.
Ja also.
Interessante war, dass ich mich völlig unabhängig und ohne Erkenntnis äh dieses äh Videos äh,
in verschiedenen kurzen Diskussionen auf Twitter äh auch mit der Frage,
auseinandergesetzt habe, ja Herdenimunität und überhaupt wann, wann
ist es denn jetzt wirklich vorbei und wie wie entwickelt sich das, dass denn jetzt äh und äh so die Gedanken, die ich mir dabei gemacht habe, habe ich dann äh halt heute äh,
praktisch eins zu eins äh in ähm dem YouTube.
Äh Video von ja Mike, Maity,
Äh glaube ich, heißt die richtige Doktor M.
IT äh.
Dieses hm äh nur in Kim, genau, nur in Kim. Ja, dieses dieses Enguien ist irgendwie ähm.
Wie ungewohnt, ja, aber es wird wohl irgendwie neun oder neun ausge.
Gibt tolle tolle Videos, die die Aussprache erklären, da habe ich mir auch alles schon angeschaut, aber ich habe trotzdem schon wieder vergessen. So.
Egal, ja, okay, äh aber zur Sache. Ähm zur Sache äh,
aufgehängt hat sich das hat sich das so bei mir an der Frage,
der Herdenimonität, weil da jetzt auch auf Twitter die Frage aufkam, ähm na ja,
Jetzt mit der englischen B eins eins sieben Variante da,
müssen wir auf eine so hohe Durchimpfungsquote der Bevölkerung kommen, dass das praktisch unrealistisch ist, das heißt wie sollen wir jemals Herdenimunität?
Bekommen, wenn der Virus immer ansteckender wird und wir Kinder nicht impfen können und,
bestimmte andere Gruppen nicht impfen können und sich Leute nicht impfen lassen, so hört es ja nie auf und ähm.
Da dann der Punkt das mit der Herdenimunität äh oder,
sagen, überschreiten einer Herdenimmunitätsschranke äh bedeutet, dass mh.
Die dadurch, dass es nicht mehr zu so vielen Takt.
Kommt. Beziehungsweise wenn ich, wenn ich halt jetzt pro Tag zwanzig Kontakte habe.
Fünfzehn davon sind geimpft, denn äh habe ich dann nur fünf Kontakte äh effektiv bei denen es zu einer Ansteckung kommen kann. Das heißt äh mein RWT
sinkt dadurch, je mehr Leute geimpft sind und ab irgendeinem Punkt sinkt er dann,
unter eins ohne, dass sich irgendwas,
machen muss. Also ab einem bestimmten Durchimpfungsgrad und wenn der unter eins ist, wissen wir, läuft sich die,
Infektion von alleine tot, ohne dass wir jetzt noch groß was machen müssen.
So viel die vereinfachte Theorie in der Realität ist es aber viel komplexer, weil.
Erstens ja die ganze Bevölkerung und auch die Impfungen, das ist ja alles nicht so eine homogene Mischung, sondern du wirst in manchen,
Gruppen, die jetzt in miteinander in Verbindung stehen wirst du eine deutlich niedrigere, in anderen eine höhere Impfquote haben. Äh du wirst andere Altersverteilungen,
haben und äh sodass halt das,
erstmal dann nur Durchschnittswerte sind, dann wirken die Impfstoffe ja auch nicht zu hundert Prozent, dann ist es auch noch unklar, äh können.
Leute, die geimpft sind oder immun sind, das Virus, aber auch wenn sie selber nicht krank werden, in dem Sinne können sie's trotzdem weiter tragen. Äh vermutlich,
sind sie nicht auf jeden Fall nicht so ansteckend, das wissen wir jedenfalls von von anderen anderen Krankheiten und ja,
insofern ist halt das Thema Herdenimmunität jetzt äh,
gar nicht äh oder nur von zentraler Bedeutung ähm wenn man jetzt gerne Eradikation äh hätte oder das Ganze komplett zum zum Stoppen äh bringen äh will,
dann ja, aber ähm wir werden außerdem möglicherweise noch Motationen sehen hin zu noch.
Ansteckender und eventuell noch harmloser ähm und äh wir sind jetzt schon an dem Punkt, wo.
Wird Herdenimunität möglicherweise gar nicht erreicht werden kann in dem Sinne
aber das ändert nichts daran, dass ein Großteil der Bevölkerung äh und fast alle, die sich impfen lassen, eben auch geschützt
sind, so. Was man dann leider nicht hat, ist der automatische Schutz für den,
Rest der Impfverweigerer, äh die dann halt kein Impfschadensrisiko tragen müssen, also die Schmarotzer kriegen nichts ab äh und äh leider aber auch eben dann,
die Gruppen, die,
Immun geschwächt sind oder sich nicht impfen für die kein Impfstoff zur Verfügung steht. Äh die sind dann eben.
Nicht durch die Herden, äh durch eine Herdenimonität äh geschützt, aber alle anderen positiven Effekte einer hohen Impfquote bleiben,
trotzdem nur wird der Virus möglicherweise
eher indemisch werden damit rechnen halt die meisten äh Fachleute, das heißt wie andere Grippe oder Schnupfenviren, wenn die gängigen vier
anderen verbreiteten Chorona-Viren sind eigentlich eher so als Schnupfen oder Erkältungsviren
bekannt und ähm machen jetzt eher wenig Probleme und wird damit gerechnet, dass eigentlich auch äh Jakobi neunzehn sich so genau eigentlich in Richtung Schnupfen entwickelt oder in Richtung Grippe
in Anführungszeichen mit Grippe ist, ein anderes Virus jetzt äh insofern äh also es kann jetzt kein Corona Virus jetzt im Grippevirus notieren oder.
Ja mehr so Husten, ne?
Ja und ähm indem ich.
Bedeutet, dass äh ja sich dieser Virus,
eben viele andere Viren,
der Bevölkerung festsetzt, dass er nie ganz weggeht und dann ähm hier und da überlebt, dann im Winter aufflammt und dann im Sommer,
wieder weniger wird aber das ist auch kein Problem, weil an sich ist.
Selbstkowit neunzehn sowas, was man gängig auch als Kinderkrankheiten.
Zeichnet oder sehen kann. Das heißt es gibt eine ganze Menge Viren die sind wenn man sie.
Als Kind so im Alter von drei bis fünf Jahren typischerweise äh infiziert man sich mit einem Haufen Deserviren,
kommt damit als Kind mit den meisten einigermaßen gut klar und hat dann, wenn dann,
später die wieder grasieren oder eine etwas andere Variante grasiert, dann
hat man aber keine schweren Verläufe mehr oder ist vielleicht sogar bis ans Lebensende Immun oder hat sozusagen so eine kleine Auffrischungsinfektion damit, aber alles nicht so dramatisch. Während wenn man
eben
bestimmte Krankheiten als Kind nicht kriegt, weiß man weil die Empfehlung okay, weiß nicht, wenn du bis vierzehn oder so war dann früher der Sechzehn keine Röteln gehabt hast oder so oder musste ich unbedingt dagegen impfen lassen. Heute,
wie gleich glaube ich früher sogar die meisten Impfungen bei Kindern, aber der Punkt ist, äh, dass.
In dem Moment, wo der Großteil der Bevölkerung geimpft ist oder es schon mal hatte, sind.
Jeweils nur die Jahrgänge der Neugeborenen.
Erstmal empfänglich über äh mehrere Jahre, aber wie gesagt, denen macht es nichts und alle anderen ähm sind entweder Immun oder haben keine schweren Verläufe mehr. Das heißt, das ist die.
Wahrscheinlichste Szenario wohin äh sich ja Kowit neunzehn,
entwickeln wird. Wobei aber auch eine Iradikation jetzt nicht komplett unmöglich ähm,
erscheint, aber es ist eher unwahrscheinlich, dass wir das hinbekommen und es ist auch zunehmend unwahrscheinlich, dass wir wirklich Herdenimunität bekommen in dem Sinne, dass,
Ja
Sich das komplett von alleine totläuft und auch die letzte Viruskopie vom Planetenerde verschwindet, wie das mit Saß eins der Fall war.
Ja das heißt wie lange dauert's jetzt noch.
Zehn Jahre.
Das kriegen wir auch.
Ja, äh ja.
Also.
Also mit zehn Jahren meine ich jetzt das,
Szenario bis wir diesen Zustand, den ich gerade beschrieben habe, also bis dann Kowik neunzehn zum Schnupfen und zur Kinderkrankheit geworden ist. Das ist eine
Größenordnung von zehn Jahren. Aber äh ich hoffe und glaube nach wie vor daran, dass wir irgendwann,
im Sommer soweit äh dann doch.
Durchgeimpft sind, dass äh wir.
Wieder einigermaßen normal agieren können, aber muss man auch jetzt schon erwartungsmanagement betreiben. Hm.
Wenn wir zu dem Punkt kommen, dass wir ja erstmal die Alten.
Durchgeimpft haben zu einem sehr, sehr großen Teil, dass die halt im Wesentlichen geschützt sind, muss man erstmal noch der Versuchung widerstehen und zu sagen, okay äh.
Die Alten sind geschützt und der Rest muss halt sehen, wie er klar kommt. Wir machen jetzt auf, kann es sein, dass.
Genauso viele Leute sterben, weil halt dann äh zwar vielleicht nur noch einen Zehntel,
oder ein Fünftel,
im Verhältnis zu den erkrankten stirbt, aber dafür fünf oder zehnmal Loll, so viele Leute sich plötzlich einstecken, sodass es so sagen ein Szenario, was droht, was wir vermeiden müssen und.
Das zweite Szenario ist, dass wenn wir jetzt an einen Punkt kommen, wo wir in der Gesamtbevölkerung eine.
Impfquote haben, die unser Air beginnt deutlich zu reduzieren.
So, das wir den Eindruck haben, oh wow,
super äh die Zahlen gehen runter. Wir brauchen jetzt gar keine Maßnahmen mehr. Dann kann es sein, dass wir auch wieder plötzlich,
einen Wachstum hinkriegen, weil nur in Kombination aus Impfung und Maßnahmen wie einen R unter Eins halten können,
in einem gewissen Zeitraum und wenn wir da wieder äh zu früh.
Alles lockern oder zu früh unvorsichtig werden, aber da sozusagen zwei Fallen. Also es gibt auf dem Weg jetzt äh ins ja in die Corona Erlösung noch so ein paar Stolpersteine,
in die wir reinlau.
Erlösung. Ja, den wollen wir alle. Den wollen wir alle nehmen.
Ja, ich habe dem gar nicht so viel äh hinzuzufügen. Ich meine ich muss sagen, ich äh habe zwar langfristige.
Na ja, Hoffnung, Erwartung in gewisser Hinsicht, aber.
Ich lasse mich davon grade nicht so dominieren. Also ich denke mir bei allem auch immer ein wenig so ja gut, könnte.
Könnte, könnte passieren, könnte gut laufen, so. Also grundsätzlich wirklich eh optimistisch in die Zukunft, aber so was so die konkrete Zeiterwartung betrifft, bin ich nicht so festgelegt.
Also es wäre für mich jetzt wäre zwar doof, wenn jetzt irgendwie der Sommer noch so ein bisschen dran glauben müsste, ja. Ich meine Vermutung ist eher, es wird so eher so in diesem Rahmen ablaufen wie letztes Jahr und das war so irgendwie so, ja okay
Hund,
komme ich komme ich auch noch mit klar. Ja, Festivals und so weiter, gibt's alles immer noch nicht, schwierig und so den Branchen muss geholfen werden, aber,
man kann dann irgendwie auch ein Leben führen. Und derzeit ist es mir so ein bisschen egal, weil so Januar, Februar, da kann man irgendwie auch drauf verzichten.
Scheiße.
Ich finde ja den den Februar in äh,
Deutschland als einen der schlimmsten Monate äh überhaupt.
So, äh weil ja in den Januar kommt man irgendwie immer ganz fluffig reingerutscht, so mit
Weihnachten und Neujahr normalerweise, das sorgt dann für so ein bisschen Ablenkung und dann ja und Januar ist halt auf
kalt und Winter, beim Februar kommt dann immer das Gefühl oft nicht so langsam. Also langsam reicht's auch mit der Kälte und so
aber im Februar ist es dann noch gefühlt ewig hin, da kommt
noch dem März, der oft auch echt kalt sein kann und im April ist auch noch nicht so entspannt und im Mai dann
so langsam äh geht's dann los, aber von Februar,
Mai ist halt noch echt so eine Durststrecke und deswegen fand ich's früher,
immer ganz nett den Februar irgendwo in warmen Gefilden äh zu verbringen. Das ist der beste Monat dafür, aber ja,
das steht einem im Moment auch nicht wirklich frei oder zumindest nicht, wenn man wie ein halbwegs vernünftig ist.
Genau, Erwartungsmanagment. Also ich hatte äh wie hier schon oft gesagt, so äh ohnehin jetzt bis Ende März keinerlei Erwartung. Und ich glaube, die die,
die habe ich auch bekommen.
So ist es so. Also so das bis Ende März dachte ich mir, kriegen wir hier nichts auf die Kette und wenn wir Glück haben, wird's,
dann besser und wenn ich nochmal zurückblicke auf unsere Zahlenanalyse von heute,
ja genau das ist das, was in diesen Zahlen so drinsteht, ne? Und äh
Ja, dann wollen wir hoffen, dass wir's bis Ostern irgendwie äh noch auf die Kette bekommen haben. Wäre super, wenn wenn man die Schulen bis Ostern noch zulassen könnte. Das würde wirklich wirklich helfen
ja? Ansonsten wird's einfach äh schwierig und dann zieht sich das halt noch länger. Und man.
Ja, also die null, ja, die null neun äh.
Sind so das, was noch so gerade.
Akzeptabel ist, wo man das Gefühl hat, okay, es geht
voran und ist man hat wenn wir die null Komma neun schaffen ist zumindest mit vier bis sechs Wochen beziehungsweise ja zwei, drei Monaten
es ist da ein Ziel da so oft um auf beherrschbare Zahlen wieder zu kommen. Aber selbst wenn das nur einen Ticken hochgeht und irgendwie mit einem R bei eins das,
finde ich ist dann einfach so zermürbend, weil man das Gefühl hat, man schränkt sich ein,
aber es führt zu nichts. So man kommt nicht.
Runter wirklich und deswegen ja null neun bisschen also null acht würde ich mir wünschen.
Da werden wir das jetzt noch zwei Monate durchhalten, dann ja können wir langsam mal darüber,
nachdenken, ob und in welchem Umfang wir dann ganz ganz vorsichtig locker? Ganz, ganz vorsichtig.
Was wir natürlich dann eigentlich positiv dazu kriegen sollten, wenn wir irgendein Punkt, ich sage mal, wenn wir die zwanzig oder die
zehn unterschreiten oder vielleicht sogar schon bei dreißig, je nachdem ähm jetzt Neuinfektionen pro Woche pro hunderttausend Einwohner,
Ähm dann werden die Gesundheitsämter auch wieder
effizienter bei der Verfolgung und Bekämpfung. Im Moment geht ja achtzig Prozent komplett an denen vorbei,
können sie nichts mehr machen so richtig an nachvollziehen und quarantänisieren. Da kommen die Quarantäne an Ordnungen äh manchmal erst zwei oder drei Wochen,
nachdem die Leute schon wieder gesund sind und.
Solche Sachen kommen halt vor, aber.
Sobald wir sagen unter so einen magischen Gesundheitsamtsabhängigen Wert kommen ähm,
ja wird wird die ersenkende Wirkung der Gesundheitsämter einfach deutlich größer werden, das heißt wir haben dann so einen gewissen Sicherheitsabstand,
aber.
Bevor wir diesen Punkt nicht erreicht haben, also bevor wir nicht unter zwanzig besser unterziehen,
sind äh bei der Neuinfektionsinstitenz sollte man.
Nicht mal darüber reden, sollte man, sollte es echt ein Tabu sein, äh darüber auch nur äh ja.
Worte zu verlieren, dass man das ernsthaft in Erwägung zieht, irgendwas zu locker.
Also machen wir das jetzt auch nicht, sondern äh wir.
Schließen jetzt mal diese Sendung äh ab, war ja auch schon wieder lang genug. Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Wenn ihr Lust habt, dann äh könnt ihr uns auf,
Luphaus äh wieder äh in einer kleinen Feedbackrunde ähm mit dazustoßen. Ich würde mal vorschlagen, Dienstag, einundzwanzig Uhr passte das, Pavel.
Mir, dass.
Das wäre dann der zweite Jan, äh zweite Februar und ähm ja, das war äh diese Woche schon ganz nett und ähm,
das tut immer ganz gut. Ansonsten könnt ihr uns natürlich auf Twitter folgen ME Unterstrich UKW ist der Twitter Account für,
diesen Kanal oder ihr könnt auch Endmeterebene folgen, dann äh kriegt ihr das volle Programm der Mieterebene mitgesteckt. Ja und ähm das war's dann eigentlich auch schon an.
Eigenwerbung, wir freuen uns auf euch nächste Woche und bis dahin sage ich tschüss und bis.
Tschüs.